cette saison le stade jean marc et celle
de montigny le bretonneux va sonner
creux les cougars qui devait reprendre
au printemps le joueront finalement
aucun match à cause du coronavirus la
fédération a décidé d'annuler la saison
un coup dur financier pour les
dirigeants du club privé notamment de
merchandising et de buvette
c'est pas qu'on soit vraiment je dirais
en complet danger mais c'est
relativement inquiétant quand même c'est
une situation vraiment inattendu les
temps sont durs pour les cougars
mais on a quand même la chance d'être
soutenue toujours au niveau au niveau
département au niveau de la région au
niveau de la mairie au niveau de
l'agglomération qui n'ont pas retiré en
fait
les budgets qui était allouée cette
saison blanche pourrait également avoir
un impact sur le secteur sportif les
cougars qui évolue en première division
pourrait perdre certains de leurs
meilleurs joueurs ce qui pourrait jouer
contre nous malheureusement c'est
aujourd'hui les championnats allemands
tchèques italiens sont en passe de
reprendre puisqu'ils ont des situations
moins perturbé que les nôtres il se
pourrait vraiment que on est des joueurs
qui avaient déjà été contacté cet hiver
puisque l'année dernière on a fait une
3e place en coupe d'europe bis on a on a
des joueurs qui avaient déjà été
contactées qui ont toujours des contacts
et qui seraient susceptibles de trouver
d'autres clubs
les cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux
espère désormais rouvrir cet été pour
les stages d'animation pour des jeunes à
partir de la deuxième quinzaine de
juillet et qui premières devrait quant à
elle reprendre en 2021